FIFA 24
nous sommes le 2 décembre 2010 à Zurich
en Suisse ce jour-là c'est le Qatar
petit pays du Moyen-Orient qui remporte
donc l'organisation de la Coupe du monde
de football 2022 par 14 voix sur 22
pourtant face à lui on retrouvait de
nombreux candidats la Corée du Sud le
Japon l'Australie et même les Etats-Unis
mais alors comment le Qatar qui avait
pourtant le pire dossier de candidature
selon la FIFA elle-même réussi à
décrocher l'organisation d'un des
événements les plus attendus au monde
alors spoiler aujourd'hui on va
évidemment se plonger dans des histoires
d'argent d'influence et d’accord secret
et vous allez le voir les Français ont
joué un rôle déterminant et au passage
on évoquera pas dans cette vidéo la
question des problèmes environnementaux
la question des ouvriers morts sur les
chantiers des stades ou même la question
des droits humains pas respectés dans le
pays selon de très nombreuses ONG non
pas que ce soit pas important au
contraire c'est des sujets essentiels
dont on parle déjà beaucoup sur la
chaîne mais aujourd'hui on va donc se
sur cette question comment le Qatar a
obtenu l'organisation de cette Coupe du
Monde et avant de commencer je tiens à
remercier nordvpn qui a accepté nous
soutenir en étant partenaires de cette
nouvelle vidéo j'avais déjà pu vous
parler de Nord-Pas leur gestionnaire de
mot de passe ou encore de Nord Locker
leur coffre-fort sécurisé en ligne mais
ce n'est pas tout en fait nordvpn et
c'est peut-être la fonctionnalité la
plus connue vous permet aussi de changer
d'emplacement virtuel un peu partout
dans le monde et ça ça peut être utile
pour deux choses déjà parce que ça vous
permet de délocaliser votre connexion
parmi 59 pays disponibles c'est utile
par exemple pour avoir accès à des
contenus géo bloqués en France mais je
m'en sers aussi beaucoup personnellement
quand je pars en tournage à l'étranger
pour avoir accès à des sites qui sont
bloqués dans certains pays où je me suis
rendu c'est la première semaine vous
aurez l'occasion d'ailleurs de voir ces
vidéos très bientôt et nordvpn permet
aussi de chiffrer votre connexion
Internet et vos activités en ligne en un
clic pour limiter toute forme de
surveillance et l'avantage c'est que
vous bénéficiez d'une protection anti
menace pour lutter contre les russe ou
encore des logiciels malveillants bref
un grand merci encore à nordvpn d'avoir
accepté de nous soutenir aujourd'hui
n'hésitez pas à checker le lien qui
s'affiche à l'écran et qui est aussi en
description pour protéger jusqu'à 6
appareils en simultané il vous permet
aussi de bénéficier de 4 mois gratuits
sur tout abonnement de 2 ans en plus
d'une remise exclusive et par ailleurs
c'est satisfait ou remboursé durant les
30 premiers jours bref je crois que j'ai
tout dit et je vous laisse donc
désormais avec la vidéo alors avant de
se plonger dans les coulisses de ces
réunions secrètes et des différents
échanges commençons par le commencement
avec une très rapide présentation du
Qatar le Qatar c'est donc ce petit pays
de 2 millions d'habitants situés dans la
péninsule Arabie qu'au Moyen-Orient donc
entre les Émirats arabes unis l'Arabie
Saoudite et le Bahreïn pendant longtemps
c'était un état sous protectorat
britannique devenu ensuite indépendant
en 1971 aujourd'hui c'est un émirat donc
un territoire musulman dirigé par un
Emir ces dirigeants ce sont les membres
de la famille altany qui règne sur le
pays depuis 150 ans alors certes le
Qatar est en superficie mais il est
connu pour être l'un des plus grands
exportateurs de pétrole mais surtout de
gaz au monde et depuis quelques années
le Qatar veut s'impliquer dans les
événements culturels et sportifs
mondiaux avec un objectif très clair
rayonné et exercer une influence par ses
moyens culturels c'est ce que l'on
appelle un exercice assez évident de
soft power les États-Unis sont
aujourd'hui évidemment assez leaders en
la matière mais tous les pays du monde
l'utilisent dans ce soft power on
reviendra là dessus juste après mais on
peut citer par exemple le rachat du
Paris Saint-Germain en 2011 le
développement de la chaîne de télévision
BeIn Sport mais aussi donc
l'organisation de pas mal d'événements
sportifs notamment donc l'organisation
de la Coupe du monde de football alors
je vous le disais selon des personnes
travaillant au sein de la FIFA elle-même
la FIFA qui est donc l'instance qui gère
le football dans le monde et bien le
Qatar était le pire pays des cinq
sélectionnés pour organiser une coupe du
monde et l'homme de la FIFA qui affirme
que le Qatar est très mal placé pour
organisé une telle Coupe du Monde c'est
lui haroldman Nicole c'est un
journaliste chilien qui était Président
en fait du groupe d'évaluation des
Mondiaux de 2018 et 2022 pour faire
simple il a notamment rédigé pour la
FIFA un rapport sur chaque pays candidat
qui résumait en fait si ce pays était
apte ou non à accueillir une coupe du
monde et parmi les critères pris en
compte on retrouve notamment la question
des infrastructures la question des
capacités sportives ou encore la
question de l'accueil des supporters
alors organiser une coupe du monde de
football aux États-Unis selon ce rapport
et bien le risque était très faible pour
l'Australie même chose risque très
faible pour la Corée du Sud ou encore le
Japon toujours la même chose le risque
était très faible mais le Qatar de son
côté était classé pays à haut risque
alors il y a plein de raisons à cela
d'abord le Qatar n'a pas vraiment de
culture du football aujourd'hui ni même
d'ailleurs une équipe nationale qui
rayonne mondialement d'ailleurs pour la
petite histoire un problème similaire
était apparu lors de l'organisation de
la Coupe du monde de handball en 2015
c'est donc une coupe du monde qui avait
été organisée et qui était tenu par le
Qatar or le pays n'avait pas assez de
joueur pour composer une solide équipe
de handball le pays avait donc décidé en
amont de cette Coupe du Monde de
naturaliser des handballeurs étrangers
pour qu'ils obtiennent la nationalité
qatari et qu'il joue donc pour l'équipe
nationale du Qatar en tant que cathari
et d'ailleurs même dans les tribunes
selon le journal Le Monde une
soixantaine de supporters espagnols
avaient été payé pour soutenir l'équipe
cathari et faire du bruit dans les
tribunes alors ensuite au-delà de
l'aspect sportif il y a évidemment les
conditions climatiques l'été au Qatar il
fait très très chaud en moyenne 36
degrés Celsius dans le pays juillet
étant le mois le plus chaud de l'année
dans le pays le problème c'est qu'en
général la Coupe du Monde justement elle
est organisée lors de l'été or vous
l'imaginez c'est assez insupportable et
pour les supporters et pour les joueurs
de faire une telle compétition avec une
chaleur aussi importante ça d'ailleurs
poussé FIFA a organisé la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar en hiver exceptionnellement en
novembre et décembre donc pour avoir des
températures un peu plus acceptables
c'est ce qui fait que la Coupe du monde
là débute fin novembre enfin je le
disais il y avait aussi un problème en
matière d'infrastructure avec un manque
de stade beaucoup de stade à construire
en finalement peu de temps pour pouvoir
bien tenir tous ces matchs c'est ce qui
fait donc que ce rapport était assez
critique vis-à-vis d'une organisation
par le Qatar de la Coupe du Monde or
vous l'aurez compris malgré toutes ces
réserves-là et bien 14 personnes sur 22
ont voté pour que le Qatar organise la
Coupe du Monde et justement ça me paraît
intéressant de faire un petit point sur
le système de vote pour l'attribution de
la Coupe du monde en gros qui vote pour
décider d'où se tient la Coupe du monde
alors faut savoir que le règlement de la
FIFA a pas mal changé ces dernières
années mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que pour les coupes du monde entre 1986
et 2022 Qatar compris donc c'était les
membres du comité exécutif de la Fifa
qui votait alors le comité exé positif
c'est en fait le principal organe de
décision de la FIFA c'est vraiment les
leaders de la FIFA pour dire ça comme ça
et dans ce comité exécutif en fait on
retrouve des représentants de chaque
continent donc l'Afrique l'asile
l'Europe l'Amérique et l'Océanie en
général c'est des dirigeants du football
influents dans leur pays et donc aussi à
l'échelle de tout le continent qui sont
représentants au sein de ce comité
exécutif et qui participent donc au vote
d'attribution des coupes du monde alors
jusqu'en 2010 pour qu'un pays l'emporte
il fallait qu'une majorité de ce comité
exécutif vote pour telle ou tel pays
soit au moins 12 voix parce qu'il y
avait au total 22 votants et c'est
d'ailleurs intéressant de noter que
c'est impossible de savoir qui a voté
quoi en effet à la FIFA le vote est
secret sauf si la personne évidemment
décide de rendre son vote publique c'est
comme pour une élection présidentielle
ou autre autrement dit donc à l'heure
actuelle on ne sait toujours pas comment
ce sont répartis les votes qui ont
permis au Qatar de l'emporter après
évidemment il y a eu beaucoup d'enquêtes
et vous l'aurez compris on a quand même
une petite idée sur le profil de
quelques personnes vous allez le voir
alors pour arriver à ces objectifs de
convaincre une majorité de membres du
comité de voté pour lui le Qatar donc
mis en place tout un tas de choses et
vous allez le voir la France est très
souvent impliquée alors commençons
tranquillement première arme importante
du Qatar obtenir le soutien de
personnalité importante et parmi ces
personnalités et bien on retrouve des
Français je suis un écologiste convaincu
je ne peux que soutenir
la candidature du Qatar à l'organisation
de la Coupe du monde de football en 2022
la personne que l'on entend juste ici
vous le connaissez peut-être c'est le
photographe Yann Arthus-Bertrand
président de la Fondation Good Planet
qui œuvre pour la protection de
l'environnement c'était un peu la
caution écologique pour le Qatar qu'il a
contacté en promettant en fait une coupe
du monde 100% écologique alors les
mirats avaient notamment promis de
compenser le gaz à effet de serre émis
par les climatisations des stades en
installant et bien des panneaux solaires
à ce moment là et bien Yann
Arthus-Bertrand avait fini par soutenir
la candidature du Qatar et ce qu'on a
appris plus tard il a eu l'occasion
d'ailleurs de l'admettre dans certaines
interviews notamment dans l'émission de
Canal+ Spécial Investigation c'est que
il avait lu le dossier très rapidement
qu'il ne pensait pas vraiment que le
Qatar allait gagner selon lui et par
ailleurs il a aussi avoué soutenir le
Qatar car il avait reçu une aide
financière des qatari pour son propre
film HOME qui est sorti en 2009 l'autre
soutien qu'on déjà évoqué et pas des
moindres c'est l'ancien footballeur
français Zinédine Zidane champion du
monde de 98 et véritable star évidemment
du football en France et partout dans le
monde je crois que c'est le moment pour
le Moyen-Orient d'accueillir cette Coupe
du Monde cette vidéo date de 2010 et
dedans et bien Zinédine Zidane explique
pourquoi il soutient la candidature du
Qatar pour organiser cette coupe du
monde et on a très vite appris que
logiquement il y avait été payé pour ce
soutien affiché alors à l'époque la
presse du monde entier avançait des
sommes astronomiques et certains parler
d'un million d'euros deux millions 11
millions d'euros aussi c'est un chiffre
qui avait circulé à l'époque alors en
2019 Zinédine Zidane a pris la parole
sur le sujet il affirme avoir touché en
fait 3 millions d'euros 3 millions
d'euros versés directement à sa
fondation la Fondation Zinédine Zidane
qu'il avait créé en Algérie avec son
père et d'ailleurs Zinédine Zidane n'est
pas le seul sportif à avoir publiquement
soutenu la candidature du Qatar on peut
citer par exemple l'ex footballeur et
actuel entraîneur de Manchester City
l'espagnol Pep Guardiola ça c'est donc
pour les soutiens officiels de
personnalités au Qatar mais ce n'est pas
tout le Qatar aurait mis en place des
versements d'argent à certains membres
de ce comité exécutif de la FIFA en
effet quelques années après
l'attribution de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar et bien des accusations de
corruption ont commencé à voir le jour
en effet en 2014 le Sunday Times un
journal britannique a affirmé que le
Qatar avait acheté l'organisation de la
Coupe du monde à ce moment-là un homme
est particulièrement visé par l'enquête
c'est l'homme d'affaires cathari Mohamed
benamam il était à l'époque
vice-président de la FIFA et président
de la Confédération asiatique de
football donc en gros il représentait
l'Asie au sein de la FIFA le Qatari
aurait versé des sommes d'argent un
certain nombre de dirigeants du football
dans le monde notamment des
représentants africains qui ont voté
lors de l'attribution du Mondial et
selon des documents consultés par le
Sunday Times et bien certains de ces
dirigeants du football en Afrique ou
même personnellement demander de
l'argent à Mohammed benamam via des
emails en gros pour dire les choses en
influençant les fédérations africaines
l'homme d'affaires katari aurait
finalement acheté le soutien de tout le
continent africain pour le Qatar le
continent africain qui détenait trois
voix sur les 22 de ce comité exécutif et
d'ailleurs pour la petite histoire suite
à cette affaire je vous passe tous les
détails des procès ou autre mais Mohamed
benhamam a été banni à vie de la FIFA
mais cette influence ne s'arrête pas à
l'Afrique et là on arrive à un moment
clé de cette attribution contestée la
troisième stratégie mise en place par le
Qatar et peut-être la plus importante
des accords secrets qui ont été passés
notamment avec la France et là on va se
concentrer précisément sur un déjeuner
qui s'est tenu à l'Elysée à Paris donc
le 23 novembre 2010 neuf jours donc
avant le vote à Zurich alors ce déjeuner
qui était censé rester secret a été
révélé en 2013 dans une enquête du
magazine
football alors qui était présent à ce
fameux déjeuner il y avait d'abord
Nicolas Sarkozy qui était donc président
de la République à l'époque lors du
déjeuner il y avait aussi l'ancien
footballeur français Michel Platini qui
était à l'époque le président de l'UEFA
donc l'instant de football qui gère le
football européen mais Michel Platini
était aussi membre du comité exécutif de
la Fifa Michel Platini elle est donc
être amenée à voter et se prononcer sur
une potentielle candidature du Qatar et
justement selon un certain nombre de
médias contre pas mal de choses qui ont
été négociées lors de ce déjeuner et
bien Michel Platini est allé à porter
son vote et son soutien au Qatar il y
avait donc Nicolas Sarkozy il y avait
aussi Michel Platini et enfin il y avait
deux dirigeants Catari selon les
enquêtes de plusieurs médias il y avait
d'abord l'actuel émir du Qatar qui était
à l'époque le prince héritier
de l'époque qui était considéré comme le
cerveau de la candidature du Qatar pour
la Coupe du monde alors selon France
Football mais aussi d'autres médias qui
ont mené l'enquête plus tard et
notamment d'ailleurs les journalistes de
Radio France et de compléments
d'enquêtes le but de Nicolas Sarkozy
avec ce déjeuner aurait été de
convaincre Michel Platini de voter pour
le Qatar puisque et bien Michel Platini
avec une grande influence au sein de la
FIFA et souvent interrogée sur ce sujet
Michel Platini assure que avant ce
fameux déjeuner il comptait déjà voter
pour le Qatar il a d'ailleurs assuré par
la suite avoir voté pour les miracles
car il voulait offrir au Moyen-Orient sa
première Coupe du monde sauf que et bien
plusieurs éléments viennent ternir ou
nuancer cette version officielle
présentée par Michel Platini et laisse
penser donc que et bien c'est Nicolas
Sarkozy qui a convaincu et poussé Michel
Platini à soutenir et à voter pour le
Qatar alors le premier élément c'est
cette note de l'Elysée adressée à
Nicolas Sarkozy la veille du déjeuner un
document qui a été consulté par les
journalistes de l'émission de France 2
complément d'enquête et par la cellule
d'investigation de Radio France dans ce
adressé à Nicolas Sarkozy on lit ceci le
rendez-vous du 23 novembre se fera en
deux séquences avec la première de 12h30
à 13h entre Michel Platini et le
président Michel Platini devrait être
réservé sur cette candidature lors de la
première séquence du rendez-vous
naturellement devant vos autres sa
position doit être plus favorable pour
comprendre donc face à Nicolas Sarkozy
il y avait des chances que Michel
Platini soit d'abord réservé à l'idée de
voter comme ça pour le Qatar et selon
les journalistes qui ont enquêté sur le
sujet l'objectif de Nicolas Sarkozy
aurait été de convaincre au Michel
Platini d'adopter une position plus
favorable au Qatar et on verra juste
après pourquoi d'ailleurs l'ancien
directeur de la communication de Michel
Platini William gaillard qui a été
interrogé par la police sur ce sujet à
affirmé que pendant longtemps Michel
Platini n'avait jamais évoqué un vote
pour le Qatar et qu'il avait au
contraire dit aux Américains qu'il
allait voter pour eux j'ai même allé
plus loin en disant que Michel Platini
avait une sorte de mépris pendant
longtemps pour la candidature du Qatar
qu'il trouvait je cite loufoque vous
l'aurez compris donc suite à ce déjeuner
sa position aurait évolué mais alors
qu'en est-il vraiment et que s'est-il
passé lors de ce fameux déjeuner et bien
l'ancien président de la FIFA le Suisse
Seb Blatter a affirmé dans un entretien
en journal Le Monde datant de novembre
2021 que ce déjeuner avec Nicolas
Sarkozy c'était je cite la première fois
qu'une intervention politique avait
changé une grande décision du football
il affirme même que Michel Platini l'a
appelé juste après ce déjeuner en lui
disant que Nicolas Sarkozy lui avait
recommandé de voter pour le Qatar une
version que Michel Platini va l'aurait
compris a toujours nier ce qui interroge
par ailleurs c'est que dans les mois et
même les années qui ont suivi cette
attribution de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar et bien de nombreux accords
commerciaux ont été actés entre la
France et le Qatar j'ai évoqué
brièvement à l'instant mais le 30 juin
2011 le Qatar par exemple
acheté pour 70 millions d'euros le club
de football très endetté à l'époque du
Paris Saint-Germain un prix jugé à ce
moment-là très très avantageux au vu de
la situation générale du club or à
l'époque et bien le PSG appartenait au
fond d'investissement colonique capital
un fonds d'investissement qui était
dirigé à l'époque par un certain
Sébastien Bazin qui était ami avec
Nicolas Sarkozy alors selon complément
d'enquête et France 2 la question est
donc de savoir si Nicolas Sarkozy a
passé un deal pour obtenir l'attribution
de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar afin que
en contrepartie et bien le Qatar rachète
le club à un prix très avantageux
d'ailleurs toujours selon complément
d'enquête des messages ont été retrouvés
par les enquêteurs sur le téléphone de
Sébastien Bazin des messages en lien
avec ce fameux déjeuner du 23 novembre à
l'Élysée il est donc évoqué un certain
deal qui pourrait se faire après le 2
décembre le 2 décembre ça vous dit
peut-être quelque chose puisque c'est
précisément la date à laquelle le Qatar
a remporté l'attribution de la
évolution de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
et bien le Qatar multipliait les
déclarations publiques suggérant que les
avions de la France pouvaient
potentiellement l’intéresser alors
toujours selon complément d'enquête
cette vente d'avion française Rafale au
Qatar était là aussi au menu du déjeuner
à l'Elysée entre les Qataris Nicolas
Sarkozy et Michel Platini en gros ce
vote de Michel Platini pourrait avoir
débloqué l'achat par le Qatar d'avions
français alors on ne sait pas exactement
ce qu'il s'est dit ni ce qui a été
conclu mais ce qui est sûr donc c'est
que cinq ans plus tard sous François
Hollande une commande de 24 avions
rafales a finalement été signé entre la
France et le Qatar pour un montant très
important de 6 milliards d'euros bref
pour résumer vous l'aurez compris selon
les journalistes de France 2 Radio
France ou encore Mediapart et France
Football qui ont enquêté sur le sujet ça
ne fait pas de doute un accord important
a été passé lors de ce déjeuner en
échange donc du vote de Michel Platini
pour le Qatar bon maintenant qu'on sait
ça très rapidement des enquêtes
ont-elles été ouvertes la justice alors
ça fait maintenant 12 ans finalement que
cette attribution contestait a eu lieu
et plusieurs enquêtes pénales ont eu
lieu où sont encore en cours en France
aux États-Unis ou encore en Suisse
commençons rapidement par la France le
parquet national financier qui est en
fait une institution judiciaire chargée
de traquer la grande délinquance
économique et financière a confié en
décembre 2019 un juge d'instruction des
investigations pour corruption active et
passive et recèle et blanchiment de ces
délits alors j'en suis conscient c'est
très flou dit comme ça mais la justice
enquête notamment sur ce déjeuner donc
du 23 novembre 2010 et selon les
enquêteurs l'hypothèse d'un deal entre
la France et le Qatar et tout à fait
plausible en effet la conclusion d'une
note de synthèse de ce même parquet
national financier dater du 26 novembre
2019 affirme que ce déjeuner a constitué
je cite un tournant décisif et à
favoriser l'attribution de la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar passons maintenant
rapidement aux États-Unis la justice
américaine a finalement
plus en avril 2020 après trois ans
d'enquête que trois membres
sud-américains du comité exécutif de la
Fifa avait reçu des pots de vin donc de
l'argent pour voter en faveur du Qatar
lors d'une réunion du comité exécutif de
la FIFA en 2010 enfin autre enquête
qu'on peut citer rapidement en Suisse la
justice enquêter pour blanchiment
d'argent et gestion déloyale la Suisse
est intéressée notamment à un virement
suspect de 2 millions de francs suisses
émis par Seb Blatter à Michel Platini et
je ne rentre pas dans les détails là
dessus mais je vous mets des liens
directement en description si vous
voulez en savoir plus c'est donc pour un
petit état des lieux de toutes les
enquêtes menées par la justice par
ailleurs c'est important de noter que
suite aux critiques et suite aux
pressions qui ont suivi cette
attribution et bien l'ex patron de la
FIFA Seb Blatter avait lui-même commandé
une enquête interne à la FIFA en juillet
2012 il avait donc désigné cet homme
l'avocat américain Michael Garcia qui
avait notamment travaillé pour Interpol
à l'époque de s'occuper de cette enquête
interne or et bien au bout de deux ans
Michael Garcia avait finalement rédigé
un rapport de 430 pages mais la FIFA
avait refusé de le publier assurant
vouloir je cite la protection des
témoins alors un résumé de 42 pages donc
10 fois plus court à vie finalement été
publié en novembre 2014 mais si j'ai une
version qui a été complètement relu et
modifiée par rapport au rapport original
et d'ailleurs on signe de contestation
de toutes ces modifications et bien
Michael Garcia avait d'ailleurs
démissionné de son poste en décembre
2014 là où ça devient intéressant c'est
que en juin 2017 le média allemand build
qui s'était procurer une copie justement
de ce rapport à publier le rapport dans
son intégralité et on y apprenait que il
y avait de nombreuses pratiques
douteuses sans pour autant et bien
indiquer de preuves matérielles au final
plusieurs anciens aux responsables de la
FIFA ont été arrêtés ou exclus pour
diverses fautes graves vous l'aurez
compris l'attribution de la Coupe du
Monde 2022 au Qatar cache encore
aujourd'hui à pas mal de mystères ce qui
est sûr par contre c'est que depuis ce
vote du 2 décembre 2010 la FIFA a en
juste d'avoir banni pas mal de personnes
revu ces procédures depuis 2018 en effet
la Coupe du monde ne s'attribue plus sur
les seules votes du comité exécutif mais
en fait aujourd'hui c'est une sorte de
suffrage universel avec les 209
fédérations qui sont membres de la FIFA
en tout cas si cette vidéo vous a plu
pour nous soutenir et ne pas louper les
vidéos suivantes vous pouvez vous
abonner dès maintenant il y a plein de
belles choses qui arrivent des
reportages des interviews des
décryptages sur des sujets sérieux comme
des sujets géopolitiques mais aussi sur
des sujets plus légers vous l'avez vu
notamment la semaine dernière avec
l'interview de Pierre Niney qui a fait
le même format que ce que j'avais pu
faire avec par exemple Bill Gates il y a
quelques mois sur cette même chaîne
Youtube notre travail est aussi
disponible sur une autre chaîne Youtube
la chaîne dédiée aux actus du jour une
chaîne Youtube ou chaque jour avec mon
équipe on vous prépare une plongée
quotidienne dans l'actualité et les
informations importantes du jour pour
rester au courant facilement de
l'actualité enfin dans cette vidéo j'ai
cité énormément de médias différents qui
ont travaillé et enquêté sur ce sujet là
je vous mets donc le lien de toutes ces
enquêtes en description je vous les
recommande vivement pour mieux
comprendre plus en détail tout ce sujet
là qui est forcément assez complexe
merci au passage à toute mon équipe qui
a travaillé avec moi sur cette vidéo
notamment blanche qui est journaliste au
sein de l'équipe et qui a travaillé
justement sur ce sujet prenez soin de
vous et on se dit à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo